we all know a Keith Urban has given us  some of country music's biggest hits as  a solo artist from his early songs like  you look good in my shirt somebody like  you to his ballads like blue and your  color but he frequently teams up with  some of the country music's biggest  names it even crosses genres  collaborating with stars we would least  expect so an honor of key stay on  October 26 rounding up his top five duet  [Music]  you please see me they all know me I  gotta get back now that the ones Allah  let me suffer you never let you go  there's nothing in the world filled the  place  [Applause]  pouring rain the Sunday morning coming  Amazing Grace but if those tear-filled  eyes up to the sky  as a backlight sleep  back when  everyone  [Music]  money was  [Music]  so did all your favorites make the list  who would you like to see Keith Urban  collaborate with let us know in the  comments below